this is a chance to talk and it's
precious and the day may be coming when
that becomes dangerous and the loss of
the free market is a grievous thing that
will impoverished us all but that will
be connected perforce as it must be by
the loss of our constitutional freedoms
too and that means that the work we do
here first of all we should savor it
while we have it but second we should
understand and get ready to fight to
protect it thanks for being here
Thank You dr. Arnn and now on to our
main speaker of the evening Daniel
Hannan is a writer and journalist and
has been Conservative member of the
European Parliament for southeast
England since 1999 he writes extensively
for newspapers around the world such as
The Wall Street Journal and currently
authors a blog for the Daily Telegraph
that you can read online his latest book
is the New Road to Serfdom a letter of
warning to America very appropriate and
we will have copies available for you to
purchase of the new Road to Serfdom out
in the foyer immediately following this
evening please take advantage of that
and mr. Hannen will sign your copy
Daniel Hannan is also in great demand as
a speaker my husband and I had the
privilege of hearing him last year in
London and it was a fantastic evening so
on this topic of the New Road to Serfdom
lessons to learn from European policy
please welcome our speaker Daniel Hannan
and II to thank you for your kind words
ladies gentlemen let me begin with a
story that seems apt to our present
discontents Almighty God decides that
he's had enough of human wickedness he
decides he's going to send a flood and
start all over again and in order to do
this he's going to find one good man so
he sends his Archangel down to this
world and the Archangel approaches know
her and he says Noah the Lord commands
that you build an ark that you Hewett of
gopher wood that you build many rooms
therein and that you pitch it within and
without with pitch Noah replies go
forward oh no I couldn't do that it
would contravene the --use sustainable
habitat directive Gabriel carries on he
says the Lord commands that of length it
be 500 cubits and of height it be 50
cubits and of width 30 cubits and now
says cubits I can't work in cuba's I
don't even work in feet and inches it
would be against the --use metrication
directive Gabriel says the Lord commands
that you fill it with two of every
living creature each male and female
after its kind of cattle - after their
kind and a foul - after their kind and
of every living thing that crawls on the
earth each after its kind male and
female and Noah says haven't you heard
of the --use transport of live animals
directive well the Gabriel is very
puzzled by this and he returns to his
maker and he says Lord what is this II
you where of thy children speak and God
replies verily the EU is the cause for
which I'm sending the flood
well well my friends he is sending the
flood now the waters are rising in
Brussels even as we sit enjoying our
dinner here in Atlanta today will be
remembered as the day that the project
collapsed 27th of October 2011 now the
collapse doesn't always happen overnight
like Wiley coyote in those Roadrunner
cartoons you go off the end of the clip
near the cliff and your your feet are
still whirling round until you look down
and you realize what what has happened
but the reality if you look at what has
just been agreed in this summit is that
we have run out of Road we're off the
cliff there was a debt crisis in Europe
governments were living beyond their
means they were encouraging consumption
but they were not producing and they
were bridging the gap with debt the EU
solution is more debt unprecedented debt
a trillion euros and literally
unimaginable sum our minds are not
designed to comprehend figures of such
magnitude the problem was jamming
divergent economies into a single
monetary policy the problem was
excessive political integration too much
centralization the EU is solving it with
more integration if monetary union
didn't work let's have economic Union
let's have fiscal Union let's have
common economic governance if it hasn't
worked let's do it twice as hard well
just stand back it's always the same
pattern whenever you have one of these
summits the markets spike for about 48
hours before people realize that none of
the fundamental problems has been
addressed and none of the fundamental
problems here has been addressed you
cannot apply a common monetary policy to
widely differing economies that was just
as true before the summit as it is today
and let's just let's just focus for a
second on this extraordinary figure of a
trillion euros which is going to be
somehow magic out of the air two
questions immediately arise first of all
who has a trillion euros
right I mean if any government around
the world had a trillion euros lying
around don't you think they would have
spent it in the last three years given
the condition of the world economy
so from whom are we borrowing the answer
of course is we're borrowing from our
children and our grandchildren we are
phrasing future generations with an
unprecedented level of debt even more
immediate arises the question what's the
cultural for a figure like that right
who stands guarantor to a debt of a
trillion euros well in theory the answer
is the European Central Bank in reality
the European Central Bank is already so
weighted down with junk debt from
stricken eurozone economies that on any
normal definition it is already a bad
Bank so who stands behind the ECB the
taxpayers the taxpayers of the eurozone
including the taxpayers of Ireland
Portugal Spain Italy and Greece right
just think about this the guarantors are
the same people as the debtors no new
money is coming in it's all just being
repackaged that people borrowing are the
same as the people lending now as I
understand it you have a word for that
on this side of the Atlantic it's called
a Ponzi scheme and people go to prison
for doing it that's what I mean by
running out of Road now why is it that I
am burdening you with our problems well
they're going to become your problems
too because this is a road which you are
following us down now john winthrop your
countrymen in mind there you know the
guy who preached the city of the hill
sermon or the eyes of all people should
be upon us he made a he made another
sermon which is much less well known and
he it contained a line where he said a
good name for a child serves as a thread
around the thumb gives us something to
live up to now that's pretty that's a
pretty tough thing if your name as mine
is is Daniel he was a hard act to follow
and it's very difficult
anyone to aspire to follow him in wisdom
in sanctity or indeed in speaking truth
to power but it did make me very
familiar with the story that again seems
very appropriate to Europe's present
calamity remember the story of
Belshazzar's feast a king is there and
he's having a party and he celebrates
and he asks for the gold from the Temple
of Jerusalem to be brought forth and he
starts toasting in the gold all of the
the gods of wood and metal and so on and
then the writing appears on the wall in
a finger that moves and then disappears
meanie meanie tech hell you fast him
nobody can read it none of the great
magician magicians can understand what's
been written the queen mother says I
your father knew a guy this Jewish man
Daniel call him in well my biblical
namesake comes along and he says with
words that apply perfectly to our
present rulers he interprets the the the
writing he says God hath numbered thy
kingdom and finished it thou art weighed
in the balances and art found wanting
ponder that phrase weighed in the
balances and found wanting it turns out
that the wealth we thought we had wasn't
there it had been fabricated it wasn't
backed by anything all through the
Western world and this is your problem
just as much as it's ours we and when I
say we I mean the people in government
for people in central bank's the people
in academia have encouraged this bizarre
notion that you become rich by spending
more now that is I was talking over
dinner to him to Larry about the danger
of half education the danger of being
just educated enough to think you're
smarter than everybody else you almost
have to be a trained economist to
believe that it is possible to spend
your way out of debt to borrow your way
out of recession and yet this is the
ruling orthodoxy of your Federal Reserve
of our Bank of England of the European
Central Bank
and what we have seen in the past four
years is the inevitable end of applying
that policy if you carry on spending
more and more without producing anything
and bridging the gap by getting deeper
and deeper into debt there comes a
terrible reckoning and rather than admit
that our policymakers have done
everything they can to keep the bubble
inflated the air is trying to rush out
what is supposed to happen when you have
a decade of easy credit when you've had
central bank's the world over keeping
interest rates too low for too long what
is supposed to happen is it there's a
correction that the malinvestments of
the past ten years are put right so that
growth can begin again on a more
realistic and sober basis but what we
saw in Brussels yesterday and what we're
seeing here is a last-ditch attempt to
stop that happening to postpone the
inevitable you know what it's like it's
like a drunk postponing his hangover by
remaining drunk it doesn't work and it
makes a hangover worse when you
eventually get there if we dealt with
the Greek crisis in 2009 the whole thing
would have cost about 60 billion euros
now a hundred billion have been gone and
no one thinks that the underlying
problems have been solved of all of the
lines of junior john maynard keynes
which are are quoted perhaps the most
common was his observation the practical
men men who think of themselves as being
free of all ideologies are in practice
the slaves of some defunct economist
never has that observation been so true
as today with keynes as the defunct
economist in question what would have
been regarded as a totally cranky
bizarre way of looking at the world
until he came along has become the
prevalent orthodoxy among intellectual
circles but not in the wider countries
if these bailouts than these
nationalizations have been put
referendum here or in Britain or
anywhere else they would have been
rejected what we see yet again is that
people are wiser than their leaders now
the reason that this has happened is
precisely because the leaders have been
able to escape the critical scrutiny of
their electorates Larry quoted Madison's
observation that this was the first
truly representative government and it
was but with every shift in power from
the 50 states to Washington from the
elected representative to the Federals
are from the citizen to the government
it becomes less representative and as it
becomes less representative it becomes
more prey to vested interests to
lobbying to the big corporations of left
or right who stand in the way of the
majority interest I I saw some of the
Occupy people in a US city where I was
yesterday and and ever I was I was
talking some people from from Northern
California at the table over this was in
San Francisco they were they were
occupying San Francisco's we are the 99%
except obviously was California so it
was summer 17 where the policy and talk
is obviously if you were in the majority
there you you wouldn't be speaking
English and you know I wanted to say to
them as I do to their equivalent English
offshoot is brilliant they're called
occupy the stock exchange but being kind
of hapless and hopeless lefties they
couldn't actually get to the stock
exchange so they instead decided to
occupy some pauls cathedral on grounds
that is kind of vaguely near to the
stock extreme and in both cases you you
want to shake these people and say you
have picked the wrong target comrades
you know I totally understand why you
are angry about these bank bailouts
everyone should be angry about them it
was outrageous that ordinary taxpayers
were sent the bill in order to rescue
some very wealthy individuals from the
consequences of their own errors of
course you should
and have to be on the far left to see
this for what it is which is taking from
the poor to give to the rich but
whatever you call it it is not
capitalism in a capitalist system bad
banks would have failed their profitable
operations would have been bought by
their more successful competitors some
bondholders some shareholders would have
lost money maybe some depositors but the
taxpayer would not have contributed a
penny you guys I want to set them you
guys are in the wrong place you should
be occupying the Fed you should be
occupying the Bank of England you should
be protesting against the people who
decreed this outrageous policy designed
as it is to worsen our plight and
lengthen the recession if you wanted to
do all the things since the Lehman's
collapse to make things worse
quantitative easing ultra low interest
rates subsidies nationalizations
everything designed to keep the zombie
banks malodorous lee wandering around
when they should be collapsing to keep
the poor businesses in play when they
should be being taken over by better
once we have ticked every box we've run
out of road where wily coyote over the
edge of the cliff now I said that this
happens when government becomes remote
and this is what might save you this is
why the EU is so much further down this
road than the United States but we can
see you in our rearview mirror and
you're under this present administration
you're doing your best to catch up but
the genius of this republic the sublime
principle that actuated it was that
glorious let's call it Jeffersonian
ideal that decisions should be taken as
closely as possible to the people that
they affect and that's what has served
to keep the government small and the
citizen big it's what's served to remind
your politicians that they are servants
and not rulers up until very recently
now to see why that matters to see what
the alternative is look across the
Atlantic if the US Constitution was
designed around the basis of maximum
dispersal maximum devolution of power
the European Union was derive design
from the opposite imperative maximum
concentration of power the EU has the
misfortune to be a child of its time
whereas your Union was born out of a
popular revolt against a remote and
unpopular government and sympathy of
your Patriot leaders was therefore with
the maximum dispersal of power the EU
came out of the second world war and
people were therefore determined to
amalgamate the countries and to make
their rulers immune to public opinion
invulnerable because the in air eyes
public opinion was a very dangerous
thing it led to demagogues and fascism
and war and so they vested supreme power
in the hands of technocrats of experts
who were immune to the ballot box the
supreme power in the European Union is
held by 27 unelected commissioners now
you'll have spotted by now that they're
not really that expert I mean if these
are the experts we're in trouble
right it's precisely because we've
elevated in Europe the standing
apparatus area over representative
democracy that the state has grown if
budgets are set not by elected
legislators who are answerable to the
taxpayer but by people who are
themselves part of the executive and
therefore personal beneficiaries from
state spending budgets are going to grow
if you shift power from people who have
to go back regularly to the voters and
explain what they've done with their
money to people who don't budgets are
going to grow and the further parlor the
further power is shifted from the
general population the more you open the
doors to all of the vested interests who
would never win in an open ballot and
that's why I say Europe is in front of
you but you are beginning to catch us up
if I look at the policies being pursued
by this administration they are not a
set of random initiatives that happen to
have been lashed together they amount to
a comprehensive Europeanisation package
European healthcare European welfare
European daycare European college
education European carbon taxes European
nuclear disarmament European foreign
policy
I was asked on a radio show here did
what did I think about this theory of
Barack Obama being born in Kenya I said
no way he was obviously born in Brussels
and I tell you my friends I am therefore
inhabiting your future or at least the
future towards which your present rulers
are intent on taking you I've been a
member of the European Parliament for 12
years I've seen what happens when these
policies of tax and regulation and
government control and telling the
private sector what they're allowed to
pay people and all the rest of it I've
seen what happens when they are taken to
their logical conclusion you are not
going to like it
don't take my word for it look at what
has happened in the past 48 hours in
Europe where the money has run out our
Treasuries are empty our credit is
exhausted and the system is in collapse
why do I come here and tell you these
things as an Englishman why do I come
here and him the praises of a republic
that was after all born out of a popular
revolt against the British crown well
I'll tell you I think we are heirs to a
common heritage and a common tradition
and this was something that was very
much in the minds of your patriot
leaders at the time of the division they
didn't believe that they were dreaming
up a set of arbitrary and abstract
freedoms from scratch they saw
themselves as part of a tradition that
stretched back deep into our past back
through the Glorious Revolution back
through the English Civil War back even
before the Magna Carta to that folk
right of anglo-saxon common law this
extraordinary idea that law does not
emanate from the government but that
rather the government is subject to a
law that comes from the people that the
state is not the source of authority
but the people are sovereign that is my
country's greatest export our supreme
contribution to the happiness of mankind
the glorious idea that laws ought not to
be passed nor taxes raised except by
elected representatives
and that vision found its purest and
most sublime expression in the old
courthouse in Philadelphia now I've seen
in the country where this vision was
first adumbrated I've seen what happens
when it's put into retreat as power has
passed in my country from Parliament to
the standing bureaucracy under
sovereignty has passed from the British
people to the European Union I've seen
what happens when you lose those
freedoms I'm terrified to think that it
might be happening here in the one place
I'd always looked to be the secure
vessel of Liberty I mentioned I came
here from Northern California yesterday
like some of the people in the audience
and they're an irresistible metaphor
struck me there I was where most of the
wine in the United States is grown of
course those vineyards came from
European stock originally they had been
the the grain the the various varieties
of grape had been introduced from French
and Italian and Spanish vineyards
towards the end of the 19th century
there was a plague in Europe a blight
called Phil Ochs era the vineyards were
wiped out and in order to resuscitate
European viticulture in order to bring
back new cuttings the wine growers of
Europe had to come to California and
bring back the cousins of the grapes
whose ancestral stock had been wiped out
in Europe now I see something similar I
used to dream of a similar thing
happening in politics what I've stood
for since I became an elected
representative in version has been a
restoration of our traditional British
freedoms devolution of power direct
election of public officials localism
devolution of power all of the things
that you take for granted here all of
those wonderful ideas that we exported
and that we've now lost in the mother
country imagine how they would have felt
those European wine growers if when they
finally got to California they
discovered that the aphids had got their
first
and that the eggs were on the leaf and
there were no vines to take home with
them that's my fear when I see you going
down this road when I see this
administration repeating all the
mistakes that we've made on our side of
the Atlantic I don't say that you've got
everything right in this country I don't
say that the u.s. is perfect I don't say
that we've got everything wrong in
Britain but it is bizarre that the bits
of the European system you are intent on
copying are the bits that have most
spectacularly and obviously failed you
deserve better my my friends you deserve
better and we expect better let me
finish by making a plea to you and I
make it as your kinsman and as your
friend and as your ally but also as a
common inheritor of that shared
patrimony of the english-speaking
peoples don't repeat our mistake cleave
fast to the vision of your founders
treasure the inheritance you have from
your parents and pass it on intact to
your children
okay time for questions Andy - you'll
wave at me when we've run out of time
will you wonderful thank you thank you
so much for those enlightening remarks a
brilliant question thank you very much
I'd like to know how many of you there
are in the EU Parliament and what your
opposition says when you tell them the
kind of thing that you've told us
tonight we have very few in the European
Parliament I am working to put myself
out of a job by which I mean that I am
working towards the day when there are
no more British members of the European
Parliament because Britain has left the
European Union now you can imagine that
you can imagine that that doesn't make
me the most popular person in the
European Parliament is one thing to
impose the termina bit on yourself is
another to try and take some of the
other swine with you as you go but I
think we are in the majority among the
peoples there is this enormous mismatch
between people and elites in Europe as
here and as everywhere else every time
there is a referendum on closer European
integration in any country in Ireland in
France in the Netherlands let alone in
Britain where there and put the question
there is a massive vote against giving
Brussels any more powers and the
response in the European Union is always
the same carry on regardless people
didn't understand the question
they didn't really mean it I'm reminded
of that eerie poem of Bertolt Brecht's
which finishes wouldn't it therefore be
easier to dissolve the people and elect
another in their place that could be the
official slogan of the European Union so
I like to think we're popular in our
constituencies but in the European
Parliament well I can best answer that
by quoting your American writer Upton
Sinclair it is very difficult to make a
man understand something when his salary
depends upon his not understanding it
it doesn't seem like anybody would have
been surprised when you have the
European monetary unit of countries were
able to build up as much debt as they
did so that's why they actually like put
some rules in place about the allowable
debt but so what happened in terms of
the fact that they decided they just
weren't going to pay any attention to
those well the rules were never observed
and not only were the rules not observed
the bailouts that we have seen to date
are utterly illegal I don't just mean
that they are not provided for in the
trees I mean they are expressly
prohibited article 1 to 6 says it is
illegal for one member state or for the
EU to take on the debts of another and
nobody in Brussels really denies that if
you point out to them that what they're
doing is against the dots and commas of
their own treaties they say yeah yeah I
thought that politics was a lovely
phrase at one of the EU's politics is in
front of the legislation on this you
know will make up the rules after after
the event retrospectively to justify
what we've done you know the crazy thing
about this is that they are prepared to
pay any price in order to keep the
project going because they personally
have invested so much political capital
in it and that price is going to be
extraordinary can already see what it is
for the peoples of Greece and Ireland
Portugal that price is poverty deflation
and emigration on a scale not seen
before and for the peoples of Austria
and Germany and Finland and the other
contributor countries that prices
massive tax rises all rather than admit
the mistake all to save face these
Eurocrats have the most expensive faces
in the history of Europe since that of
Helen of Troy which was said to launch a
thousand ships
rather than admit that they were wrong
they are prepared I almost said they are
prepared to pay any price they
personally will not pay any price
because as Eurocrats they are exempt
from national taxation but their peoples
will pay a terrible price
to what extent do you think the
fundamental problem here is an ethical
problem the new serfdom being
indebtedness as you know the Bible warns
against indebtedness doesn't prohibit
but it warns the debtor will be the
slave of the creditor and one of the
things that Keynes and the Fabian
socialist did was to try to teach this
in the school system to get people to
believe that there's nothing really
wrong with borrowing there's there's no
reason not to and honoring your word you
see and prudence have become less
important as ethical issues and so my
question I guess is is this a
fundamental long-term thing that we need
to work at through the schools to get
control of our debt in it's it's a
mindset
it's a worldview and as educators we
have to teach this and of course I don't
have to tell you most of the teaching
comes in the home so and what has
happened to homes what has happened to
families I could go on and on about this
but what I'm trying to say is we look at
this is just a problem for legislators
or the wealthy the rich the wall
street's
but no it's a fundamental problem for
society the whole area of greed wanting
what's not yours right well first of all
that's if that ethical education has to
come from you from people in families
from people as private citizens it
should not come from governments
governments do things very badly they
were no good at building cars they were
no good at operating Airlines they were
no good at installing telephones and
they are no good at instilling virtues
they're very good at nationalizing
morality and excluding virtue because
they
push the private sphere in to the
corners but they can't promote these
things and it's a dangerous politician
who believes he can but on the substance
of your question there are different
kinds of debt there is there is
borrowing in order to invest because
you're starting a business or whatever
and there is borrowing for the sake of
consumption and our problem throughout
the West is that we have been borrowing
and consuming without any equivalent
production and the worst offenders have
been the government's you're right this
is something this policy that on which
every Western economy has operated since
the war where you deliberately
manipulate interest rates so is to
punish thrift and reward profligacy
flies in the face not just a biblical
teaching flies in the face of every
classical philosopher of every classical
writer of every monotheistic religion
and of common sense it's this phenomenon
of the half-educated again the people
who have colonized our central banks and
our academia but the one lot of people
who profit most from it are the
government's themselves what's happening
now in Britain what's happening here
with the quantitative easing and what's
going to happen now in Europe because
the only way that they're going to
finance this trillion euros is through
printing money is a massive under clared
tax on the people who have done the
right thing the phenomenon inflation is
a way for the state to transfer revenue
from savers to itself and the reason
politicians do it is because a country
which has a big deficit can close that
deficit in one of three ways it can
reduce spending it can raise taxes or it
can inflate the debt away politicians
are always attracted to option 3 because
they believe that they can get away with
it the voters won't blame them but the
voters will see inflation as some kind
of natural force of the politician had
to deal with rather than as a
consequence of the politicians own
action you know what people have seen
through that they're taking us for fools
I don't think that people are going to
fall for that we know perfectly well
there if you print more money if you
increase the supply of anything other
being equal you cheapen its value and I
think the governments are behaving
outrageously they're being unmanly in
there they're refusing to admit why
they're doing it and they are hurting
the people who have done all the right
things there's a lady there and then
there's a and then there's a lady at the
table right at the front here if you
have not seen her the microphone
wielders yeah so quick question thank
you for coming over here now educating
us short of scrapping the whole system
you know short of just getting up there
and I'm a capitalism revolt what steps
if you had a chance to start with some
initiation which you talked will be most
impactful immediately well I do think
you have to change the system I mean you
guys here had a very good system and a
number of peculiarities of the American
system of democracy primaries term
limits recall votes ballot and and
referendum procedures dispersal of power
states rights these are all bollocks
against the power of an overweening
state and the danger here is that people
are trampling over them you know the the
the the extraordinary thing of having a
regulatory czar you know I find the Czar
bit of the title even more scary than
the regulatory bit I mean here was a
country I thought that was founded on
the premise of getting away from all
that sort of thing but we'll leave that
to one side we need to copy that
or rather we need to re-import these
ideas when I when I make these arguments
in Britain about why we need elected
sheriffs and why we need local sales
taxes people say you're trying to
Americanize our system I say yeah and
where did they get it from but what I
want is to is to repatriate our
revolution but I come back to saying
this that people are ahead of the
politicians and what happened as far as
I understand it at the midterms last
year was exactly what's supposed to
happen that groups of Concerned Citizens
seeing that their elected leaders were
not safeguarding their freedoms and were
conniving at an unconstitutional
expansion of state power took the
defense of their freedom into their own
hands and began the process of chain
the complexion of their legislature so
that it was more in tune with public
opinion perfect that's how the system is
supposed to work your congressmen are
not the owners of your liberties they
are their temporary and contingent
stewards and if they're not doing their
job properly you change them
you found him petit I know you believe
or give President Obama the benefit of
the doubt that he intends well but this
Occupy Wall Street and other things
there are rumors it's infiltrated by
Marxists and communists in labor unions
and all this stuff and I read Saul
Alinsky one time and he said that the
thing to do is to create enough chaos
that people will turn to government for
all their solutions could you see that
motivation behind this when I say that I
think he is acting from principle I do
believe that the worst as I as I said
over dinner Susan the worst atrocities
in politics are carried out by people
who are convinced of their own rectitude
the most dangerous thing in politics is
the man who is so convinced that he has
a monopoly of the truth that he regards
anyone who disagrees with him
intellectually as morally deficient and
therefore someone to be trampled over
the shyster in politics the guy who's
just gone in to better himself
financially he realizes very quickly
when the game is up and he gets out
without having done the terrible damage
that the wrong ideologue does now I was
talking to Anita
earlier about the parallels between the
second Roosevelt and the present
president and those parallels in a way
are obvious they they both take over at
a time of economic crisis what looks
like a failure of capitalism they both
bring these enormous Democratic
majorities in their wake in both houses
they are both convinced that the crisis
was caused by the inactivity of the
previous lot and that therefore almost
anything they do is justified because
they alone are trying to rescue the
little guy and that in their minds
justifies sidelining the legislature
ignoring the Constitution expanding the
executive Obama hasn't gone so far as to
try and pack the Supreme Court but only
because he saw somebody else try and
fail to do it before I'm sure that all
of those things aren't done by people
who think that they're rescuing the
country but that's why your founders had
the genius to design
a system where they were constrained
where that wasn't enough you were not
just answerable to your conscience
you are answerable to your constituents
that's why I come back to saying it is
the most precious thing we all take
things for granted it's human nature and
I'm sure that a number of people in this
room take for granted the unique
properties of US democracy in all its
extraordinary and myriad forms but the
most brilliant thing was the way your
founders without any first-hand
experience of it foresaw the dangers
inherent in the centralization of power
Thomas Jefferson said in a country this
size if we had a single government its
members at such a distance and out from
under the eye of their constituents
could not but give into corruption
plunder and waste my goodness he was
right about that look at the European
Union he could have been describing it
amazing it's country we now see
empirically what he knew intuitively and
that's why the solution here
every time I come back to it disperse
power you make government more efficient
you get rid of duplication you make
budget smaller you make people happier
with what's going on in Europe and I'm
over here do you think that the stage is
being set for another world war no I
think that the the knocked down
justification of the EU who is always
that they were stopping war and that in
their minds just like I was saying to
Susan that in their minds justified
anything you're corrupt yeah but we're
stopping war if Sun Democrat yeah but
we're stopping war you know and they
almost literally would say that there
was an extraordinary and terrifying
moment in the run-up to the French and
Dutch referendums on the European
Constitution five years ago six years
ago now when the commissioner in charge
was swedish lady called mrs. Wahlstrom
went to the to do it to her to celebrate
or to mark the anniversary of the
liberation of
concentration camp intelligence tat it's
a knuckle Terezin in the Czech Republic
and she actually said the people who are
against the European Constitution should
come here and see where that road leads
now that is that is the really
terrifying moral further you know anyone
who disagrees with me basically wants
another Holocaust but the good news is
that she was wrong because you know
people did vote no and that has as far
as I know been no reversion to mass
murder or genocide in Europe but the
terrifying certainty of saying something
like that anyone who disagrees with me
is basically an apologist fanaticism and
this is what kept the thing going
actually in the sense that bourgeois
democracy had spread around Europe we
had solved the problem of war in Europe
by about 1960 the European Union could
at that stage have given itself a medal
and retired but do you ever know
bureaucracy that volunteers its own
disbandment having got that far they had
to keep finding new justifications for
their existence and for their salaries
and even now they still use this way I
mean the the German Chancellor said it
yesterday in her speech to the Bundestag
you know if the euro fails we might be
back to war in Europe come on come on I
did a debate about a month ago against
two German euro files and they both used
that argument and they did it in the way
that the elites in Germany always do
they they use this very elliptical
language or we mustn't awaken the demons
of the past we mustn't go back to the
wicked parts of our history and it was a
basically German audience I was speaking
to I said you know they've said what
what the German elites always say and
they've done it in this indirect
language that they always use I said you
know why because they can't say it
plainly or you would see how utterly
absurd it is let me say it plainly and
you will see how silly it is we have to
give all this money to the Greek
government because otherwise we might
find ourselves invading Poland it is a
totally preposterous idea and happily
the German people in a sturdy
common-sense way have seen through it
they can spot a racket when they see one
sure okay one one more yes we are
problems of many and we're reminded like
you mentioned the days of Noah and we
think about the days of Nineveh when the
Defiant Jonah was sent but I must say
that I agree with Herman Cain that we
need to talk about solutions and our God
tells us that there is a solution
he says if my people who are called by
my name will humble themselves and pray
and seek my face and turn from their
wicked ways then I will hear from heaven
and I will forgive their sin and I will
heal their land
thank you well I'm not sure there was a
question although I agreed with your
answer
but I I will I will just add this the
most important virtue I think in
politics after after twelve years of
being a publicly elected official is an
awareness that you are passing through
institutions that are bigger than you
are I'm not sure that all of your
leaders here have that but I am
absolutely sure that they don't have it
in Europe there is this extraordinary
presumption this belief that they have
all the answers when we drew up the
European Constitution unlike your
founders who had the modesty to limit
themselves to some general principles
the European Constitution went into
enormous detail about the rights of
asylum seekers the status of disabled
people the policy on space exploration
you know your Declaration of
Independence promises life liberty the
pursuit of happiness
the --use equivalent which is called the
Charter of Fundamental Rights and
Freedoms guarantees our right to strike
action free health care and affordable
housing now there was a debate at the
time of the framing of the constitution
of whether it should explicitly mention
the Christian heritage
Europe and I think it well you know
given the presumption of the authors of
this document of course they're not
going to have the almighty in there
there's no space for him they've got all
the answers this is this is the Babel
story come to life they think that on on
their continent they can build and see
into heaven and that is a dangerous
thing coming back again to the
politician who sees no constraint on his
action because he is so confident in his
own conscience save us from people like
that